filling the city center thousands had
gone on strike from school this could
easily have been mistaken for a muddy
festival there was no mistaking the
headliner this is an emergency
people are already suffering and dying
from the consequences of the climates
and environmental emergency but it will
get worse well I will not stand aside
and watch I will not be silent while the
world is on fire
will you 17-year old - Swede and address
the crowd for less than five minutes
there was no denying her impact world
leaders are behaving like children so it
falls on us to be the adults in the room
peoples and protesters had traveled from
cities including Manchester Cardiff and
Birmingham if we destroy it all then we
have no other place to live
right now we are not acting we should
act now there is no planet B and also
this is our future what did you think
about Greta when she spoke do you wish
to see her yeah what do you think about
Greta
in a city which is considering banning
diesel cars and where airport expansion
was just rejected it's perhaps no
surprise that Greta Tong burg Jo's here
to attend her first UK school strike
Greta may well be preaching to the
converted here but experts say it is the
science which proves we all need to act
climate science about men made climate
change is very robust so a lot of
detection and retribution studies have
found that you know human induced
climate change and our emissions of
greenhouse gases has made some extreme
weather events such as heat waves and
sometimes storms more likely this is a
city that was taking bretter and her
cause to heart but it's those in power
she says continue to ignore the climate
emergency dan whited Sky News in Bristol